the thing that does cut through and
helps us reach new people more than
anything else are what we call sort of
super videos change my mind is adversity
within the last three or four years and
then a subsidiary of that Crowder
confronts which usually occurred because
someone threatened to kill me I changed
my mind let's go right now to a montage
of actually top moments from funded by
you on location super videos we've got
to make them afraid of somebody fake it
can we say a billion views in this
channel that's closer to two if you add
up mug Club the rest of it this is with
one piece of content on YouTube per day
it's not like a lot of these other
networks are doing 50 pieces of 30
pieces and like this is really what's
incredible we are so grateful and a big
part of this we will say that bring the
big part that brings in the most amount
of new subscribers here on YouTube
because you know search results we've
talked about a lot of these algorithms
aren't necessarily favorable to us we've
had a lot of problems like how do we
reach new audiences right well people
search steven crowder changed my mind
for the longest dozen kind of fix didn't
she didn't show up yeah and then we were
no longer able to like run videos as ad
so it's just like how do you reach new
people the thing that does cut through
and helps us reach new people more than
anything else are what we call sort of
super videos and these are videos are we
going location like anta pho we've
talked about yeah and there are two two
really ones that stick out changed my
mind is absolutely within the last three
or four years and then a subsidiary of
that Crowder confronts which usually
occurred because someone threatened to
kill me to change my mind so but these
super videos what often happens they go
viral they sort of become a news stories
opposed to commenting on the news you
know they became a news story in and of
themselves and that ultimately leads to
more people subscribing to the channel
and here's the thing I appreciate how
much everyone out there understands
sometimes if you join my club we'll have
like a week where we maybe miss two
shows right I mean yes
so usually we'll pre-tape but sometimes
we can't we just have to run and go do a
hidden-camera deal where we don't have a
hundred and forty something writers or
staff like yeah Jay Leno has or a
hundred something like Seth Meyers have
we we have 12 people here and I think 15
is count part-timers abroad and so we
just have to pack up everything go out
and tape a super video where we can't do
this show and that and we would never be
able to afford to do these super videos
if not for you I mean to give you an
idea do one like to change my mind
you'll see in front of the White House
that's getting 12 people to Washington
DC several hundred pounds of equipment
making sure that we have security when
we get there getting travel back not to
mention the editing software food hotel
typically for two days I mean you're
talking about tens of thousands of
dollars often to do these and
we wouldn t able to do it if not for mug
club and I know it's one of those things
that sometimes you don't see because
these go up on YouTube but mutt club is
paying for that it's paying for us to
reach new people because that cuts
through the algorithms and I can't thank
you enough we've actually shot a few
that are in the hopper and we're
planning on doing more of these in the
coming coming year coronavirus has made
it a little bit tough you know eggs
let's go right now to a montage of
actually top moments from funded by you
on location super videos thanks again so
much hi my name is Steven Crowder
[Music]
you want the Vitis he will not divide us
what do you think would happen if we
went into a Muslim bakery and asked for
a gay wedding you can write on it Ben
loves Steven forever and have our hands
may be holding can I get a gun here
without a background check I thought at
gun shows you didn't have to do a
background check
well you're asking it was it because of
the magazine capacity no okay yeah it
does look really sinister would you be
onboard with common sense gun reform
pencil what that means do you want any
firearms shotgun well sorry welcome to
Detroit
[Music]
we have a nice two-story in the Detroit
area cozy rustic
you guys have papers I need papers he's
mobilizing [ __ ]
waiter these homos get a load of be my
walls not a price that you're willing
yes that yes [ __ ] yes [ __ ] slang
are you familiar with the term of
manspreading we'll see what women think
using our homemade apparatus I get one
yeah
I've decided to go through the
socialized Canadian healthcare system to
show you exactly what it's really like
what a finish that means we wait and we
get judged decide how important we are
if you like wait hold up
a government employee recommending a
private clinic we've been tracking in
for a long time he was just down there
president circle and they were handing
out sharp objects the staff people with
so they had someone coming with an 8k
why did it take - late night hosts
comedians to find this out
we took a hidden camera to an abortion
clinic in Colorado where late term
abortions have been legal for years to
show you exactly what it is that they we
and you are talking about this woman was
going to enter 32 week that's eight
months her eight months old baby's life
sometimes like thank you look at this
[Music]
hi I'm Stephanie with all the
frequencies of a feminism
hold on your team I'm Stephanie and I'm
pretty sure I'm pregnant really wanted
to talk to something about plan B
[Music]
ladder with really nice mug my
cheekbones nice mug man louder louder
with proud of
[Music]
people are triggered hey YouTube what
you're about to watch is a new segment
we call changed my mind pretty simple we
go out and set up in public and pick a
topic and we actually allow people from
other points of view to come up and
proactively change my mind you are more
than welcome to change my mind if you
think I'm wrong
I am open to having my mind changed
fetus is literally a parasite like it is
sucking the life from a mother yeah
every single day like that's literally
what happens that's not even like not a
mother I'm guessing would you be willing
to maybe in a follow-up we could do a
segment on this please go with me to
arrange a shoot for the first time
[Music]
right on sergeant
[Music]
okay
[Music]
hey we grab him okay you gotta connect
all right okay all the way around look
at this how about that
look at this all different races genders
the power of dance of course there are
always those who aren't so excited to
see you all the racist steven crowder
y'all I would probably punch him
this is a cancer in parasitical society
[Music]
maybe need to reflect women period so
you should respect women I am the woman
so [ __ ] you wife before cancer if we
want to sit down with people in an ideal
scenario and be able to exchange ideas
but when they don't want to and they're
acting like little spoiled brat slash
domestic terrorists we've got to make
them afraid of somebody hey kids
you want a piece of me for a long time
hey how are you man
steven crowder what's going on we can
discuss it at a new cool meeting tonight
I'm not discussing with people admit
threats against my sunnies follows my
son when you're threatened by your
actions he said you didn't even post
this and acted like you didn't know me I
think you're a liar what do you mean by
that with it like what you meant with
killing members of ice for $500 a pop
fire if you enjoyed this video you can
subscribe or hit the notification bell
and one of these buttons or watch
another video but you know this this
thing is you don't um I mean you don't
you don't have to I'm a dive I'd like it
if you did you know I put a lot of
effort into it whatever you want